what's happening people welcome back to
the channel in this video i'm going to
take you through the ten books which
have most impacted my life we've got
eight which are personal development
books and two which are real life
stories let's get into it first up is
essentialism by greg mcewen this is a
book which probably changed my
fundamental big picture approach to life
more than anything else and it's one of
the very few life design books which
actually delivers on its promise if you
feel like you're always busy but not
getting anywhere if you struggle to make
progress towards your meaningful
long-term goals
this is for you it's a book that reminds
us to focus on the vital few and not the
trivial many it's an answer to a lot of
common 21st century problems i think
we're overloaded with information and
choices and business opportunities and
adventures and it's very difficult to
work out what we actually should be
doing for me i always loved saying yes
i'd say yes to more businesses or more
trips away with friends but i didn't
actually understand how all of that was
contributing to the end goal of what am
i actually here for essentialism forces
you to strip away everything which is
non-essential and gets you back on track
focusing on the only things that
genuinely matter as far as i'm concerned
you should start here before reading
any other personal development book next
up we've got the forgotten highlander by
alistair ercart this is probably the
most extreme story that i've ever read
so a scottish soldier is captured by the
japanese in singapore and spends three
and a half years surviving the most
brutal conditions where almost every one
of his friends die he's part of a forced
labor group who build the bridge over
the river kwai he gets left to die in a
hell ship with cannibals on board which
then gets torpedoed by a u.s submarine
he gets captured again works a mere 10
miles from the nagasaki bomb blast and
still survives it all after all of that
he kept quiet for over 50 years and
finally wrote this memoir as a call to
arms to bring the japanese to account
for what they got up to during the war
it's
a difficult book to read at times but
really inspiring it's an amazing
reminder of just how bad life could
actually be and when i'm stuck in
traffic or annoyed that my internet's
running slow or pissed that the delivery
driver's gone next door it makes me
reset and actually focus on just
it does it matter think about some of
the challenges that people have actually
faced in life and um
yeah if i haven't got dysentery for
three and a half years solid
i reckon i'm doing all right by the way
if you want more suggestions i've just
completed a reading list of the 100 best
books that i've ever read so if you want
more awesome reads you can pick up a
copy for free link is on the screen
somewhere and in the description below
next up is lying by sam harris this is a
one hour read on why you should never
lie it's hugely transformational for me
over the last few years not because i
was lying all the time or something but
just that telling the truth is actually
quite difficult especially if you're not
working on it a lot of the time it's
easier to tell a lie than to tell the
truth and without a compelling reason
for why you shouldn't lie you just keep
on slipping down that so sam's book is a
really good insight into the nature of
lying why you do it and the negative
effects that it has on you
and others in my experience telling the
truth is like a superpower you never
have to remember what you said you never
have to be concerned about being found
out for something because what you did
always aligns with what you said you did
it really does alleviate a lot of
anxiety and it makes you a lot more
proud of the person that you are
especially if you've gone through your
20s perhaps doing some stuff that were
less than honorable at times there's no
reason not to pick this book up you can
read it in a single sitting
and it might just change your life next
up we've got the ape that understood the
universe by steve stewart williams as
far as i'm concerned evolutionary
psychology is the closest you're going
to get at peering under the hood of your
own behavior and discovering why you do
the things you do steve stuart williams
writes one of the easiest and most
accessible books on evolutionary
psychology that i've ever found and he
answers some unbelievable questions like
why are we attracted to certain traits
in the opposite sex or why is jealousy a
thing are we monogamous creatures why do
we help our family more than we help
strangers or why do we make alliances
with some people and enemies of others
as someone who doesn't like being at the
mercy of my programming becoming aware
of the evolutionary impulses that are
driving my behavior was super insightful
and very satisfying to me we can't
always transcend our nature but being
aware of it is an important first step
if you're interested in human nature and
why we are the way we are you'll be
fascinated by this like it's it's
basically just an endless barrage of
jaw-dropping discoveries and it's really
easy to read i found myself highlighting
pretty much
every other paragraph next up we've got
the precipice by toby odd which is
potentially the most important book on
this entire list it's the best insight
into existential risk that i've ever
found a complete breakdown of how
humanity could go extinct the relative
likelihoods of each risk occurring and
proposed solutions so from asteroids to
artificial intelligence bio weapons to
nuclear war this is a one-stop shop for
understanding the risks that our
civilization faces and what we can do
about it the precipice really did shake
my world view quite fundamentally and
reminded me that as a steward of the
globe right now i do have a duty to all
of the future generations that are going
to come to leave this a better world
than i found it it also gave me a sense
of awe and dread kind of like when you
look up at the night sky it makes you
feel insignificant in a beautiful way
and it stretches that out across an
entire book this
for some people that i've told to read
it has changed their life and it makes
me very happy that i genuinely think
those people are going to work very very
hard in a way that's going to make
everybody else's existence improved the
precipice is a very easy read it's super
accessible and it's even easier to
listen to actually because toby's got
this beautiful australian accent it
makes a nice change from reading
personal development all the time you
can improve the texture of your own
worldview without constantly looking for
a hack that directly relates to you this
is the biggest picture that you can get
and yet it's changed the way that i go
about my day pretty much all the time
next up we've got lost connections by
johan hari this is a fantastic dive into
depression's causes almost everyone is
going to suffer with some form of
depression during their adult lives so
educating yourself on it makes a lot of
sense johan has trolled the entire globe
speaking to some of the world's most
prominent experts and drawing on
examples from history anthropology
politics and a lot more to elaborate his
points for a long time depression was
judged as an imbalance of chemicals in
the brain and that the environmental
impact was actually very small johann
turns this on its head and reminds us
that unmet needs not unrequited
chemicals are what might be causing
depression it puts you back in control
and this is what i found very liberating
about it that it permitted me to do what
i always knew was right that i have
control over my mood on a day-to-day
basis and that there are certain
pathways that i need to make sure i'm
fulfilling before i can say i have a
problem with my brain it's like look are
you getting up at the right time each
day are you eating sleeping walking do
you have friends that care about you do
you have a job that you committed to do
you have a local community that you feel
a part of if you don't have any of these
things what are you doing talking about
the way that your brain feels like your
environment is what happens first and
then you move on after that i would say
this is another book that you can
audible johann has a lovely british
accent and there's some long stories
that are probably quite good to
visualize if you want something that you
need to listen to in the car or that you
can chill out to on an evening time this
is a good show next up we've got the war
of art by stephen pressfield this is
another short and brilliant read it
breaks down the challenges of motivation
and struggles as a creative it teaches
you how to overcome procrastination and
find your creativity and properly apply
yourself to your craft a lot of people
read this book because it helps them to
get past procrastination and overcome
creative hurdles but i read it and fell
in love with one chapter right in the
middle called turning pro it reminds us
that we need to treat the pursuit that
we are going after in our lives
seriously that we need to treat it like
a professional and not an amateur that
we need to lean in to the discomfort
that we have because that's what a
professional does it made me change the
entire process that i had in my approach
to the podcast and this youtube channel
because i thought well i want to be
really really good at this so what would
a professional do in fact i think that
so many other people enjoyed this
chapter that stephen went on to write an
entire second book called turning pro
about the exact same topic if you're in
a rut with life and you need a creative
kick up the ass
this is for you half of it feels like a
motivational david goggins monologue and
then the other half feels like a
spiritual book about the esoteric world
of higher meaning you have no reason not
to commit a couple of hours to reading
this next up we've got endurance by
alfred lansing this is the best
retelling of sir ernest shackleton's
voyage to the antarctic that i've ever
found it is a terrifying joy to read so
in 1914 shackleton and his team they
tried to cross the antarctic and pretty
much
everything that could go wrong does go
wrong they face insane odds in the
harshest conditions on the planet after
becoming stranded and having to survive
for more than two years the story tracks
the entire narrative in brutal detail
which makes for a powerful and inspiring
story for me i connected with it because
it reminded me just how far human
potential can go that when i'm facing
discomfort where i think my limit is is
probably not even halfway there is so
much headroom above that and hearing
this story from an analog age you know
1914 they left just after the first
world war was declared and when you find
out about stories like sir ernest
chuckleton and the entire team of guys
including a stowaway overcoming the odds
it really inspires you to go out there
and to take on the challenges of life
with a new set of eyes next up we've got
why we sleep by matthew walker as far as
i can see the world is split into two
camps the first one are people who do
understand the impact of sleep on your
health and your performance and the
second one are the people that don't i'm
a club promoter and for a long time i've
worked until three or four a.m multiple
nights per week so for me sleep was just
the annoying thing that i did in between
finishing work and then getting up to go
back to work again and this book is
single-handedly responsible for red
pilling me on how much my health and my
performance was suffering because i
wasn't prioritizing sleep i think this
is the only book that you need on sleep
in my opinion and if you don't
understand the effects on your health
and your longevity then dedicate some
time to it here you find out tips for
how to improve and optimize your sleep
insights into the function of why we do
it for the human body and a lot more
again this is probably one that you can
afford to audible you don't need to
necessarily take away any of the
statistics you just need to overall
adopt the mindset sleep is really really
important and the more that i do it the
better my performance will be finally
we've got models by mark manson this is
probably the only book that you need as
a man to become effective at dating so
manson went on to superstardom after
this but the book is still a classic it
breaks down the root behaviors that
cause female attraction and it gives
actionable and ethical advice that most
guys need to be successful at dating
like how can you overcome nervousness or
how do you keep conversations with women
engaging and interesting how do you find
a girl who you're genuinely attracted to
the reason that i really like this book
is because previously a lot of the
dating advice i'd got especially for men
was a bit icky it felt
quite
predatory in a way and it was all about
oh you've got to neg the beater and then
twist the lemon and tell her this and
whatever whatever i wasn't into that i
wanted to just understand the
fundamental principles and then allow my
personality to come through mark i spoke
to him on the podcast not long ago and
he said that this is exactly right the
purpose isn't to turn you into some
different sort of a person that can
sleep with a girl and then that doesn't
know what to say to her the next day
it's to become the sort of man that is
attractive to women again another book
that you can definitely afford to get on
audible you don't need to be writing
down too many notes just understand the
fundamentals of how attraction works and
then go out there and find your chick
let me know which of these books you
agree with and which ones i've missed
off in the comments below and don't
forget that if you want to get my full
reading list with 100 books that you
need to read before you die you can get
a copy for free by pressing right here
don't forget subscribe it makes me very
happy indeed
peace